okay this time I'm gonna help you
achieve better baking
the great thing about pastry is if you
follow the basic rules the possibilities
are endless
whether it's simple short crust or flaky
phyllo you just need a bit of practice
to get it right
my first recipe uses lovely buttery
shortcuts pastry to make a dish that's
as delicious as it is simple leek and
pancetta quiche shortcrust pastry is one
of the staples of the kitchen it is so
versatile but the good news is is one of
the easiest pastries to make trust me
when you crack it it can make a real
difference to cookies take a sip what do
you think of shortcrust pastry it's sort
of semi flaky but it's rich buttery
start by sitting 200 grams of plain
flour into a mixing bowl large pinch of
salt
Turner grams of unsalted butter clean
the bus up to room temperature if you
let the butter become too soft in the
flour so it doesn't absorb it in with
your fingers rub together first now the
secret is grab big handfuls and squeeze
the butter into the flour syllables
happened literally in thirty seconds
I've got that nice crumbly texture now
cover tablespoons of water
nothing worse when the pastry is so wet
you can't bring it together needs to
shape like a nice rich cookie dough is
just a touch too dry so one more
tablespoon of water
yeah it's coming nicely now that's what
I want a nice sort of firm ball pastry
onto the board I'm gonna use these when
the strongest parts of the body pull
towards you and push back down
use those wrists to really need it
together so just that nice sort of
smooth texture now wrapping and cling
film set that in the fridge
20 minutes really important that you let
the shortcrust pastry relaxed now to
make the quiche you can use just an
ordinary flan dish but I love making
them in mini frying pans which gives me
an extra rustic charm brush with oil to
stop the pastry from sticking
once the pastries at room temperature
roll it out to a nice even thickness
place it in the center of your little
pan turn it in don't use your fingers
because what we don't want any holes in
this just get a little bit of dough cuz
that sort of acts like a little sort of
mallet strands it out nicely
I'm building a sort of extra lip because
that way I can get a filling and there's
absolute maximum levels when I cook them
blind first
blind-bake simply means to precook your
pastry before having the filling this
ensures you'll have a fantastic crisp
pastry add a sheet of foil or baking
paper and weigh it down
you can use rice pulses or ceramic
baking stones just make sure you keep
them for the next time and feel them
turn to degrees for 10 minutes now for
the filling under a classic quiche bacon
and leeks this is a amazing cured
pancetta
pancetta is the ditalion cured meat made
from belly pork seasoned with things
like juniper nutmeg fennel a great
substitute is unsmoked bacon as Ivan
cheddar gets lovely and crispy finely
sliced leeks and add well links and
bacon nice really important to cook
those links down exactly once
those leeks have almost sort of
caramelized slightly crispy the flavors
amazing
I just drain them off so any excess fat
gets trained the tablespoons of cream
and gives it any nice of richness
I want to third garnish ie bacon and
leeks in my quiche and one third of a
savory custard touch of salt
touch a pepper migrate sangria cheese
that makes a really nice sort of creamy
less of an eggy quiche take my amazing
crispy pancetta and leeks in hmm give it
a good mix these one more little thing
some freshness flat leaf parsley
incredible really important just to
taste the mixture with the quiche
filling ready next finish off the pastry
remove the fallen weights and return to
the oven to get it lovely and golden all
over
[Music]
now when we fill them give that a really
good mix up
[Music]
beautiful great over some more cheese
which will bubble up and melt
beautifully then into the oven
make your keys for 15 to 20 minutes
[Music]
incredible it's got that nice sort of
cheese on toast mouth on the top it's
sort of bait but the secret of any good
quiche is in the short crust because
that's the hero
there are lots of different types of
pastry so to help you put you on the
road to pastry perfection here are three
of my simple pastry recipes that you can
easily cook at home first up my
indulgent chocolate tarts
first combine softened butter and sugar
and cream it'll soft breaking an egg and
mix well next folding the flour put the
mixture onto a floured surface and
simply need it lightly till it's well
combined then shape into a disc and
chill then simply roll out your pastry
until it's about a quarter of a
centimeter thick cut into small disks
then gently press into lightly grease
Lou's bottom mini tart tins and prick
the bottom to prevent the pastry from
bubbling breast in the fridge this
ensures that when the pastry bakes it
will turn out nice and soft then bake it
till golden as they cool made the
gorgeous silky chocolate filling place a
mixing bowl over a pan of gently boiling
water this is known as a man marie then
add double cream butter and plain
chocolate then stir until it melts and
is Dossi and smooth then pour it into
the crisp and golden pastry cases and
simply tap to level and chill until set
so easy so indulgent and so delicious
eating with crème fraîche ice cream or
simply by themselves perfect my next
dish is an irresistible take on a
latin-american classic beef empanadas
first finely chopped onion and garlic
sweats in the pan of hot olive oil until
tender add paprika cinnamon and cumin
and stir cooking the spices off
intensifies the flavor add beef mince to
the pan brown and seasoned add chili
flakes for a fiery kick next dried
oregano chopped green olives and chopped
boiled eggs once it's mixed through set
aside to cool for the empanada cases
roll out puff pastry this stuff's so
time-consuming to make it home so do
what I do cheat a new shop-bought cut
into disks spoon the mixture into one
half of the disk leaving roughly a
centimeter border around the edge brush
the edge of one half of the disk with
egg and fold it over crimp the edges
with your fingers to seal and remove air
pockets
then simply cook in a medium oven until
golden brown
super easy super quick and super tasty
servo chimichurri a spicy South American
herb celsa
this is what Cornish Pasties dream of
being when they grow out my next dish
uses superfine phyllo pastry and as a
variation on a Moroccan classic easy
chicken bestia
first chop onions ginger and fry them in
hot olive oil add cinnamon and to give
the mix a subtle sweet note a pinch of
sugar then seasoned chopped cooked
chicken thighs and add to the mix pour
in chicken stock and then simmer
stirring whole lightly beaten eggs which
thicken the sauce and cook and in sliced
almonds then set aside to cool now build
your pasta phyllo is another pastry
that's tricky to make it home but you
can buy fantastic phyllo Xochitl brush
each sheet with melted butter and lay
four sheets into a greased baking tin
[Music]
spoon in half of the fantastic aromatic
chicken filling add four more buttered
sheets of phyllo pastry
and simply piling the rest of the
delicious chicken finally cover with a
couple of sheets of filo and fold over
all the drape sides brush with more
butter then bake in the hot oven for 10
to 15 minutes until the top is crispy
and golden brown you and all the fina
paste wonderfully crunchy and golden so
turn over and return for another 10
minutes
when done removed and for a different
but delicious sweet finishing touch dust
lightly with icing sugar and cinnamon
intensely aromatic sweet and savory
crispy and succulent an extraordinary
pie that has to be tasted to be believed
three types of pastry three
mouth-watering fillings three more
recipes you can stake your life on
that's so simple to do beautiful for
easy accurate baking you need the right
kit don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment here's my
quick guide to two essentials you need
for baking scales and a sieve bacon is
so popular now
these scales are absolutely essential
especially you have to follow the recipe
to the exact grammar these digital
scales are so easy to follow they can
convert from pounds and ounces to kilos
and grams more portly so much easier to
use than your mama's old weights
absolutely perfect a sieve make sure you
get one with a long handle and balancing
hooks so you can rest it over your
mixing bowl or a Pam an easy thing to
have in the drawer cost nothing it's so
effective especially with bacon with
these two pieces of kit definitely on
the right road to baking like a pro be
it bacon or any type of cooking always
pays off to use the best ingredients you
can find and you'll never too old to
learn from the experts
next our shopping guide to getting the
best milk and cream
when it comes to name what makes great
quality milk dairy farmer charlie ray is
your man he's been producing milk from
his herd of hand read specialist breed
jersey cattle for over 30 years yeah
they're part of the family almost so
he's up teased when he's in the stuff
the jersey milk is very high butter fat
which therefore means it is very cream
is very creamy to drink and it's the
best quality milk you'll get anywhere
Jersey cows have very docile very
friendly very easy to manage and this is
my favorite she's about 17 years old
she's called misty if you think of the
large arctic milk tank as you see going
up and down the motorways she's filled
one and a half of those on her own
[Music]
I reckon these are happy kills they've
got a draw roof over their heads they've
got a dry bed and they've got as much
food as they want the happier they are
and the better kept they are the better
the quality of the milk that comes out
the other end this is what's called an a
breast milking parlor the other way as
much as we've got contact with the cows
who can treat each cow individually the
milk goes up through a meter into that
line through a big filter and into the
tank without this product you wouldn't
have chocolate cheese yogurts it's the
base ingredient in so many things that
you buy and totally take the brand food
and where there's milk there's also
glorious cream essential for brilliant
bacon and lots of savory dishes too
[Music]
single cream is around 18% fat so is the
lighter option for topping desserts or
stirring into savory sauces
whereas double cream at nearly 50% fat
is lovely and rich in Panna cottas or in
a carbonara sauce as well as being able
to withstand boiling whipping and
freezing sour cream sound with a similar
culture to that used in yogurt is a
really tasty topping for chilies or
baked potatoes clotted cream rich thick
and a delicious indulgence sir with
puddings and scones or in ice cream to
make it extra rich and mascarpone
actually a creamy soft Italian cheese
famously used in Italian dessert
tiramisu it's also fantastic in
cheesecakes
[Music]
it is positive all life in great bacon
as with all cooking sometimes less is
more the easiest dishes look and taste
spectacular when they're done well and
it doesn't come any simpler or more
stylish than my next dish wonderful
baked cheesecake for me food always has
to be impressive but when it comes to
desserts often you see spun sugar or
wall decorations remember simple is
always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious mouth cream cheese leave it
have the fridge for 5 or 10 minutes
they're nice and soft trust me
your arms will be thanking you sugar in
this cheesecake is New York cheesecake
because it's baked
there's no base start creaming the
cheese and the sugar spending the amount
of time I do in the States if there's
one thing they know how to do out there
is the most amazing impressive
cheesecake rich delicious but so simple
work the vault lift the ball to your
advantage
really whisk whisk whisk whisk lovely
nice and creamy now your eggs
add the extra mixture bit by bit do it
this way
it's more efficient hey you're
incorporating a lot of air be the
mixture doesn't separate last though
your egg lovely of course you can use
electric mixer but why go to the gym we
can just make a cheesecake a day
cheesecake add a keep the bingo wings
away now couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk stop them your lumpy now
I want to send a cheesecake over the
freshness zest for the lemon in there I
want to sort of tart it up even more
fold in some fresh raspberries so just
mix them through be careful to crush
them then grease the cake tin with
butter this will ensure your cheesecake
slides out beautifully take your mix now
that fall in now take your cake tin and
just tap it mixture hits the bottom of
the Katyn the raspberries rise and
you've got raspberries at the top the
middle in the bottom and also stops all
those little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture from the cake tin
there's no holes in the cheesecake now
into the oven 180 degrees for 35 to 40
minutes
[Music]
he's slightly souffle DUP pull off
that's the color I wanted on top and
look at it it's one of the simplest yet
the most stylish cheesecakes anyway
beautiful
[Music]
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips
kicking off with how to handle pastry
lightly flour the surface pastry on top
rolling pin
now the secret now is don't overwork the
pastry firm push turn the pastry around
and this helps to even the pastry turn
and roll now as it starts to crack don't
worry just by pushing it back together
it's sort of unites the pastry
immediately apply pressure turn the
pastry now the average thickness is down
to a one pound coin back on the rolling
pin and look beautiful
so the neatest edge on tarts and quiches
my tip is to let the pastry hang over
the side of the tin when you bake it
trim around the edge once the pastry is
cooked it will give you a cleaner edge
and prevent it from shrinking
[Music]
my tip for even rising is to place cakes
and tarts in the center of the oven so
the air can circulate all the way around
them test your cake to make sure it's
done insert a knife skewer or even a
piece of spaghetti in the center if
there's mixture stuck to it it's not
done yet if it comes out clean your
cakes ready if there have any baking
beans to hand for blind baking you can
use any rice grain or pulse you won't be
able to cook with them afterwards but do
keep them to reuse them next time when
you're folding egg whites on whipped
cream into cake mixtures you want to
retain as much air in the mixture as you
can my tip use a metal spoon as the
sharp thin edge will keep more of the
air in
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and
100 recipes to stake your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking